so these people are ideologues they have
moral beliefs that they come into the
classroom with and not only do they
teach those but they test those those
kids on the beliefs and they want to
back so
it's really a
terrible situation
even if you agree with it
so think about it like this i think that
part of the problem is that people get
too caught up into right thinking and
left thinking and oh you know academia
is 90 actually portland state university
the national scholars association
found that 99 of the faculty and
administrators donated to one political
party get out of here
yeah that's true 99
yeah you can look it up the national
association of scholars and there's the
oregon association calls you you know
what that party is right of course
they're all trump guys they're all mega
guys right
yeah so so the so i i don't necessarily
think that's a problem but
because you know people can believe
anything they want but remember this is
a public institution right so this is a
public institution kids are going there
they're never hearing
from people who believe other sides of
the argument and it's the whole thing is
just so disheartening so for somebody
that's not in that world maybe give us a
visual of what that world looks like
both for students who are going there
with maybe opposing ideas as well as a
professor that's in that world
where 99 gives to one party and you're
just kind of trying to and by the way
for for the audience to know this you
were not supportive of anyone in 2016 on
the right as candidates right i don't i
don't think you were even so it's not
like you're one that's a mega team or
anything like that you're just the
professor that's trying to teach there
but maybe give us maybe give us a visual
of what it's like to be in that world
today
sure but not just 2016 i've never voted
for a republican in my life
so that's very important for the
audience to know that's very important
for the audience to know that yeah i'm
not some
not even am i not a right-wing maniac
i'm not even a right-wing guy period and
so you know i i believe i'm an atheist
as well
and i want to talk about that
in the context of your question so what
does it look like it looks like kids go
into the classroom and they never hear
the other side of the argument
they never hear an opposing view and
they certainly if they do which i doubt
but they never hear it from someone who
believes it why is that a bad thing
well
well if if you don't hear an opposing
view it's an indoctrination mill you're
going there to parrot back or
regurgitate you're not teaching people
how to think and then making decisions
on their own let me give you example so
i teach i taught a class it feels
freeing to say that i taught a class an
atheism and i'm a very out and very
outspoken atheist and i would have
people come into my class so i would
tell people exactly what i believe
and then i would have believing
christians who were qualified come into
my class and speak to the kids
and i'll give you an example somebody
wrote after my resignation letter
somebody wrote dr phil smith wrote a
letter to the oregonian he's a
conservative christian he teaches at a
conservative christian university here
in portland oregon and i gave him uh the
whole class
provided that he had a q a so he
couldn't just give a lecture so he gave
a one hour lecture and answered a one
hour q a about his best arguments for
the existence of god i didn't say a
thing
and i let the kids decide so the
students themselves make their decisions
and i viewed my job is not only to be
honest with them but to bring in the
best representatives of the other side
and so he wrote and i had no idea he was
going to do that he wrote a lovely op-ed
to the oregonian which is the local
paper here
and so what does it look like it looks
like only one view is forwarded it looks
like you can't question certain things
that are morally fashionable like equity
and most people by the way they don't
even have the slightest clue what equity
means or diversity or inclusion or any
of these things that have been
that have hijacked uh i mean these
things are now infused in our
institutions and most people have no
idea what they mean so so you know let's
start off with the basic part woke you
hear walk every everywhere i mean
obviously you and i know what walk means
but how would you define what woke means
all right it's funny you asked that i
have a video series coming out that
translates wokish into plain language
and it's a they're 60 second videos
basically woke means to be awakened to
the injustice in the world and the more
woke you are the more you understand
that you can never be woke enough
because reality is just infused with
injustice and oppression everywhere and
so
the
part of the communication problem that's
my book how to have impossible
conversations is that people are
speaking past each other so if you like
this sort of short club from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]